when you're young you're not thinking
and everybody has made a bad choice and
because you stressed out you go change
your gender because you want to try
something new once you do it you can't
go back the more you throw stuff at kids
before they develop that's
indoctrination
when jubilee created middle ground the
intention was to uncover humanity and
empathy shared among strangers with
opposing beliefs
whether your political beliefs are on
the left or the right we all exist
within our own echo chambers
so for this episode we partnered with
ground news and created a test that can
analyze your news sources and show you
their biases
the participants of this episode agreed
to take the quiz and share their results
we encourage you to do the same
step forward if you agree with the
prompt
cancel culture
is a good thing
we have the freedom to say what you want
but everyone else has the freedom to
respond and cancel you if you say
something that is racist homophobic
transphobic et cetera cancer culture is
definitely good in the means of like
um def platforming people who are
spreading very hateful messages what is
your opinion on trump being cancelled on
twitter when you
go onto twitter whatever you check the i
accept the you know guidelines the
community guidelines i agree to follow
them and he didn't follow them so
twitter has the right to
take him off the app and people that
might make the counter argument that
twitter is biased will only cancel
right-wing politicians that's not true
at all twitter and other forms of social
media have cancelled left-wing activists
there is an equal balance on both sides
you're brought up cancelling him off
twitter i'm sorry i disagree when the
taliban
can use our social media but an
ex-president can't
there is something
wrong with that does the taliban violet
community get guidelines doesn't matter
i mean i think it matters to twitter
what their community guidelines are
that's why they ban trump because trump
violated community guidelines that's
what every platform has whether it be
tick tock youtube instagram the taliban
stones people because they're gay if
they've done that and they've posted
videos of stone and gay people i agree
they should be removed and that is
fundamentally wrong
the problem is they're smart enough to
not do that
well well then why wasn't trump the
president wasn't smart enough to not do
that i guess if i'm a american and i
have to vote between this person this
person i need equal access to both of
them to decide what's right bro you
could be a klansman you could say you
hate black people that's not my job to
police your language i can't expect
everybody to love me and think the way i
think all y'all think different i mean
that's totally dope but the fact that
you want somebody removed
because they think differently that that
could be you one day do you think
freedom of speech is something that
still exists in america we do have
aspects of freedom of speech like you
can't go into a movie theater and yell
fire so obviously there are limits of
freedom of speech but they're picking
and choosing who they're silencing and
who they're letting talk if people react
negatively to what you say it goes both
ways you can't just say that
absolutely
america is becoming less and less safe
i'll leave this to you guys
so i have a lot of friends
that
have been in the military for the last
20 years because they refused to get
vaccinated they told me that they would
be dishonorably just discharged or
kicked out of the military i just
believe we're losing a lot of good
servicemen with the current situation
that we're in right now a lot of police
officers are down crime is up all over
when police aren't there
we're murdering each other at a really
high rate
police are in those neighborhoods
because the homicide rate is high y'all
can run around talking about police all
you want but i challenge any of these
liberal kids to spend two weeks in an
environment i grew up in and i promise
your perspective of change the one
advantage we have about being older
we've been through a threat or two and
our enemies
you know like china the communist party
in china they're laughing at us
you know russia is like we don't need to
do much they're gonna
screw it up on their own we need to
get the help of our younger people that
haven't been through a threat before
to realize a lot of what's going on is
not good
my name is mike i'm 59 years old and i'm
a conservative parent you know growing
up during the 1980s
you know that was a huge influence on me
and it formed my views and the people
that i was around as the reason why i'm
a conservative parent i think america
should be more middle of the road
and not be
necessarily more liberal and if anything
should be a hint more on the
conservative side because we're going to
watch our freedoms get extinguished or
encroached if we don't
guard those freedoms and make sure that
all of our children have a chance to
succeed
can they disagree a step forward
i have actually
wished i came up here for the agreeing
section because i think i interpreted
the definition of safety the same way
that you guys did but after hearing your
eyes conversation i
started thinking about how our american
people aren't safe in the face of like
imminent like climate disasters that are
coming our way and how we don't have the
infrastructure deal with that i actually
very much agree with that because i
think we need to define like kind of
like what we mean by like we're less
safe now do we mean like there's more
homicides after covid or like what do we
mean i would say
before we got rid of half our military a
half hour police force you know slavery
was legal the holocaust was legal so we
can look at all these mass atrocities
and say we're doing what's right
everybody who was a part of the
holocaust government they were doing
what hitler said they were doing what
was right so everybody
losing their job for not getting vacs
and all the vast people you got you got
who's who can we control everybody who
gets the shot that's who's going to do
what we say the enemies are coming and
we don't care about that because we want
to
care about what color we should wear and
pride and critical race theories like no
one else cares about that but us in
america that's our problem so you think
that
talking about sexual orientation and all
that kind of stuff takes away from the
safety of our country who you sleep with
has no merit in the real world what does
it matter okay let's just broaden the
scope with the chronovirus pandemic why
did it take weeks for us as a country to
mobilize together to fight to fight the
public health crisis that was already
affecting the nation it was a scam to
get donald trump out of office it's all
fake
it's my opinion i agree with you i don't
think that we could create or the
democrats could create some
international plan getting all of these
scientific communities outside of just
the u.s and even international
governments on their side for something
that they're just trying to get trump
out of office i feel like that's heavily
ridiculous trump was a was the thorn and
nobody saw it coming and they had to
find a way to get him out of there
there's no melon but voting 100 trump is
the president president right now 100
yeah because overwhelmingly mainland
ballots were divided and that's obvious
exactly that's not because mainland
ballots are fraudulent because million
ballots are actually not fraudulent at
all that this election was the safest
election in recorded history there's a
lot of videos so you see people with
fake balance so that's here and there
i'm not that's just here say for random
people on tech talk are we really gonna
like take that as like empirical
evidence it's a personal opinion
my name is parker i'm 19 and i'm a
liberal my sisters and i have
become a lot more liberal a lot more
left laying over time while my parents
have stayed a bit conservative before
when i was a conservative i kind of just
went off a lot of the indoctrination and
propaganda that was spread to me when i
was a kid i grew up on the fact that oh
we shouldn't have increased taxes
because taxes are just negatively
affecting us personal responsibility
isn't what a lot of the decisions people
make in society is based on it's mainly
based upon their environments how
they're socialized by their parents
people around them things like that
my new source is more reliable than the
other sides
when i look at conservative news i see a
lot of conspiracies that i don't
necessarily agree with and so if
everything comes from opinion and just
people developing their own ideas it
just doesn't seem reliable to me i feel
like the only way you can get unbiased
news is in order for
news media organizations to stop
prioritizing having really vivid
headlines that might not necessarily be
100 accurate i think that starts with
putting people over profit they want the
the biggest story or whatever and they
don't want to actually give the news
that would be beneficial to our everyday
average americans and i think that if we
put a lot more
focus on putting people first instead of
the big news or the big story we can
change that aspect of society i agree
with you 100 percent like i say the
civil rights movement is the civil
rights entertainment industry because
it's so profitable put a police shooting
on tv it's breaking news every headline
is on every social media you're selling
shirts you're selling signs that's so
much more profitable than showing me you
shaking hands the news media is
literally capitalizing off the emotions
of society no matter how you feel about
it handling your privacy in your house
why because if you can do it on camera
somebody's gonna make a dollar off of it
and that's not fair to you
young people today
are too sensitive
i think it's a good thing that young
people are sensitive i think today they
can be more sensitive than what they
probably could have been
30 or 40 years ago you know the growing
up was the berlin crisis the cuban
missile crisis
i mean we had the threat of
annihilation you know staring at us
several times and a lot of times i go
you know thank god john kennedy handled
it the country
has been
spoiled for so long they're trying to
make it so a man can't be a man and if
you don't let men be men then
things start crumbling society crumbles
families crumble and broken homes start
happening and kids need their fathers so
36 of kids don't have a father so every
boy is well my mom is mad at me my dad
don't love me my dad don't care about me
maybe i should be gay maybe i should be
trans i don't know who i am and your
father puts confidence in you no
disrespect anybody but the younger
generation of men are soft and if we had
to go to war they're not protecting
america there's no better place to be as
a black individual or whatever you are
in america go to the middle east right
now and say you gay or you're trans and
see how they treat you
johnny
32 years old and i am a conservative
parent my grandfather was a no excuse
individual he grew up in the jim crow
south but he worked hard the house that
he bought is still in our family today
he had a garden in his backyard if you
step past a certain way he got on you so
to watch the men
before me who really could have been
lynched for stepping out of line who
really could have went through a
hardship for not doing what society said
the worst thing that could happen to me
is i get a mean tweet or a dislike so i
gotta fully embrace who i am and i know
i can create anything with my two hands
and feet
i'm hannah i'm 17 and i'm a liberal i
really want equality for all and the
liberal
policies that have been passed side more
with my values of equality for those who
are on the lgbtq those who are
on the gender spectrum something about
conservative parents that i don't like
is whenever i come across them they seem
to be very rooted in their ways and not
willing to listen to someone who's a
teenager like me they think more like oh
because i'm older i have more knowledge
which is not necessarily always the case
can we have the disagreeable step
forward
this idea that because
men are being raised by women that
they're weaker
is
in my opinion
completely false our
generation it's not more sensitive we're
more aware of all these things being
transgender and gay is not something
that is should be ashamed of or make you
feel less in today's society that is why
women are fighting for equality because
this idea that because they only have a
mom they're weaker or because you know
they're more sensitive that's in my
opinion completely false and i would say
in the environment that i grew up in the
teen pregnancies come from girls without
fathers the homicides come from people
without fathers every girl that i know
if they grow up with a daddy they get
married before they have a kid why do
they not have fathers if you want me to
be real because a lot of women make bad
choices on the men they procreate with
if you make a bad choice that's your
responsibility every bad thing that i
did in my life it was when my daddy was
in jail
when my dad was out and i had my dad's
reassurance i was a better person i had
one daughter that had to move across the
country
to get rid of a toxic relationship with
somebody that was harming them why does
the woman have to move across the
country because the man is being toxic
why can't the man be taught don't be
toxic oh i agree women nowadays have to
deal with those kinds of relationships
the women the mother knows better i
would say than the father
about that we're not more sensitive
there's just more opportunities for us
to be sensitive you can say like 15 20
years ago there weren't videos of black
men being shot by police all over the
internet now that that's there people
are
more
inclined to feel a certain way or take a
stance on that topic do you think it
would be more beneficial to show police
also interacting with white guys because
more white guys get cold than black guys
by cops if you look at the amount of
white people and the amount of black
people there are going to be more white
people killed because there are more
white people in america the percentage
of black people that are being killed is
higher than the percentage of white
people
just because you're pulled over doesn't
mean you have to resist i mean they
don't just kill you when they pull you
over it's all about based on how you
perform as an individual i've been
pulled over and never had a bad
interaction in my life when i was rude i
got snatched out the car everything is a
personal choice and you can't take
accountability for your life and you
will forever be a slave that's not true
there are definitely issues on the side
of policing black communities majority
of black communities majority poc
communities are over policed there's
larger patrols in black communities
there are police work longer hours in
majority black communities so there's an
issue from the policing side as well
politics has damaged my relationship
with a loved one
i'm sure you could relate to this as
well but
in the asian community there's a lot of
anti-blackness so
with the
advent of the black lives matter
movement this past year having
conversations with my parents were was
really difficult especially around the
nuances of racial justice and sort of
like what the movement was fighting for
and how to articulate that and like the
very closed mindset that my parents had
a lot of my family voted for trump in
the past election and i don't
necessarily agree with that i don't like
to say this but it made me view their
morals a little bit differently and
they're willing to adapt and change
was so
different and i was just like shocked
because i wanted to understand their
side and really talk about it and i was
met with you're wrong and we don't want
to talk about it and
that kind of really damaged just kind of
the way i looked at them yeah i
definitely agree and i also think that
it just made me
less willing to expend the energy to
have
political or like just like any like
hard conversations with with my parents
or other anyone else in my family
my name is rithwick i'm 18 years old and
i'm a liberal i grew up in a low-income
immigrant household and i think the
systems that are in place right now
aren't sufficient enough to support
people americans like myself or my
family because my parents were
immigrants
i think they were liberal on issues like
immigration and things that directly
affected them i'd like to ask to the
conservative parents why they don't
necessarily listen
or adopt their own beliefs whether
political or social based on the
conversations they have with their
children and why they're so set in their
ways
you know i read a lot of the tragic
stories where family members don't talk
to each other anymore personally i think
that's sad do all my family members vote
the same no
do we have a pretty good idea of
how family members may have voted yeah
but we actually
we want more of
agree to disagree i'm not going to not
buy you a present for christmas because
you know you decided to vote for
somebody that i don't like
give me a break families are special
and we've got too many people as you've
talked about that don't have them when i
took this prompt i kind of took it more
of like
my view of the person changed
differently differently because not
because the way they voted but because
some of their values to me were like he
said moral values and that shows kind of
part of their characters would you say
that morality is subjective to each
individual person or would you say
morals are the same across the board the
basic is human equality for all
and so if you don't believe that
somebody should have an equality
based on their gender their sexual
orientation their race or anything like
that that's a moral
that's a moral problem in my eyes that's
a huge thing with the trans and the gay
and lgbtq and all that whole thing so i
grew up lds
being utah utah county it's like 95
mormon at eight years old is when you
get baptized and so if you're raised
around where 95 of people think the
exact same way i feel like that's too
young of an age where you're a child and
you don't really know what you're doing
and so where i have a problem with um
you know the trans or these different
things is
they're getting kids at like 10 12 years
old and they're pushing them down that
path who's they
who's they
who's pushing who's indoctrinating these
kids and uh becoming lgbtq and uh et
cetera there's a lot of groups out there
like i've just heard that there's groups
out there i don't know you don't think
there's groups out there that do that
no i'm a smear straight man so i think
it's weird for you to comment on the
clear experience and what that's like
for someone growing up who's struggling
with those experiences the way you're
describing it as indoctrination people
who are
figuring out their sexualities and their
career identities aren't necessarily
going to ascribe to the first labels
that are put before them if i'm not
mistaken the brain isn't fully developed
until you're 25 years old correct yeah
correct i know how i used to think at 16
man
i know how you think at 21.
man i'm not against kids doing whatever
they want it's just the order you get
you change i got my first tattoo at 15.
i'm covered now if i was a little older
i probably would have waited when you
young you're not thinking and everybody
has made a bad choice and because you
stressed out you go change your gender
because you want to try something new
once you do it you can't go back the
more you throw stuff at kids before they
develop that's indoctrination because
you're trying to get them while they're
not fully cognitive to know what's going
on
the older you get the more conservative
you become
when i got older and i had kids and i
had a family i actually started reading
policies everything about me changed
when i became a father because i had a
reason to and i'm sure you would agree
with that yeah as i've gotten older and
the environment we're in right now i
feel like they're trying to cancel the
constitution they're trying to cancel
christianity i mean most teenagers are
liberal i was i was living when i was
teen it's fun culture is liberal so hey
when you're younger you're going to be a
part of culture right when you're older
you're trying to raise your family you
don't have a time to care about what
lebron james said or who did that just
when you mature you value what's around
you
my name is sean i'm 36 years old and i'm
a conservative parent my dad's kind of
my idol i've seen him basically build a
very successful life and seen how simple
he's lived his life through prayer and
through just basic conservative
principles being raised up lds or mormon
i saw a lot of
just judgment and so i don't necessarily
believe that you know you have to be in
a religion but i do believe in
in prayer i've been all across the board
as far as the way my life has gone and
at my happiest times i've lived by
conservative values
building up what you're saying about
like teenagers we're a different
generation and so we view the world
differently and i think that's probably
why you've seen more teenagers be
liberal because we just view the world
that way but i don't think it has
anything to do with my generation i was
liberal when i was a teenager and all my
friends were too and when you're a
teenager life is fun it's just totally
you kick it you party so that's what i
get the teenage as you grow you you
either can run away from responsibility
or embrace responsibility when there's
real things going on you start looking
at life a little different versus when i
was young i didn't know about that i
didn't know about corporate gains tax
and i didn't know about my stock account
and i didn't know that i can all these
things that i didn't know when i was a
kid so when people are generally talking
about taxing the rich more they're
talking about the top 400 billionaires
that are literally paying a lower
effective tax rate in taxes than the
middle class the top 400 billionaires
pay an effective tax rate of eight
percent that's obviously not a fair
share and i think obviously everyone can
agree here that they should be paying at
least a fair share right how do you
increase taxes on someone's assets
though most of those billionaires aren't
unrealized capital gains is how they're
specifically trying to do it now but it
would be through long-term capital gains
because a lot of the people who are
paying those taxes they're paying
capital gains tax rate there's also tax
loopholes that have been lobbied into
congress by big corporations and big
businesses lobbying politicians to get
whatever they want so if you get older
and you work yourself off you become a
multi-millionaire you deserve to pay
more because other people didn't work as
hard as you but it's not because other
people didn't work as hard as me it's
because we as a society want to give
everyone access to things like basic
necessities like healthcare education
have everyone have have an equal
opportunity we don't have that right now
you can have equal opportunity of a
baseline but the outcome would still be
different because every individual is
going to work different levels obviously
right so i think that's where we are
excited i was able to pull it off i
graduated high school with a 1.9 gpa i
don't have a college degree so the only
limits are the limits you place on
yourself that's just my perspective
america is the best country in the world
i think despite all of our challenges
and problems when you look at all the
other countries of the world
everybody is still trying to come here
the way i can talk out loud though i can
feel myself the way i can express myself
fully as an individual
it ain't many places black man can go do
that outside of america three years ago
when i got into the court systems and
the different rights taken away from me
and government control and government by
power and so when you have that stuff
stripped away from you and you realize
most of their countries don't have the
freedom that america has america has
been the greatest country ever and i
think it will continue because of a lot
of good people that stand up for the
right things
i think i would like to ask the question
what is america the best at i think we
just was talking about the freedoms that
we have here versus what they don't have
in other countries so what about places
in scandinavia that actually have higher
amounts of freedom they have better
democracies than we do here higher
quality of life higher median income
they have health care systems that are
more efficient that take care of
everyone in their population more access
to education but when you look at the
big picture everybody wants to come here
millions of people are not trying to get
into scandinavia why because we have
more opportunity
than any other place in the world we
don't even make the top 25 in women
equality but we have a better
opportunity to do something about it
compared to other countries and i would
love it for europe to open their borders
the way we have and see if you can get
people from other parts of the world to
do mass
migration to europe i was going to
mention scandinavian countries as well
but i think it's also important to
address that scandinavian countries are
very like homogeneous like racially
socioeconomically they don't face the
same geographic diversity that we have
we were mentioning with the fact that we
have the opportunity to
write like women inequality like why is
that not happening it's because the way
our democracy is set up our congress is
literally in a gridlock right now as it
has been for so many past sessions of
congress we aren't getting anything
productive done the opportunity we have
here is incredible and i'm very happy
that i live here and not somewhere else
but we are so focused on oh america is
the best that we don't look at these
other countries and say why are all
those people so happy and what is that
and how can we incorporate that into our
society i mean i'll say like i think
diversity is good i think diversity of
thought diversity of pain is super
helpful um we it's really easy to get
clogged up into this group thing so i
don't expect anyone else to agree with
me or feel the way i feel i just expect
you to respect my right to feel this way
i respect your right to feel this way
and we keep it moving
100 agree i couldn't agree more actually
awesome that's a wrap
[Applause]
[Music]
you